on the sick film I was an A.D so I
always wanted to work on the crew and so
you said I want to work on the set yeah
and they were like you can do this right
you're not gonna you're gonna work hard
you're gonna they had you had to really
I think they knew they kind of knew that
um you know my work ethic was there and
all that kind of stuff and I've done a
few days on different jobs with the crew
before all right but I was contracted
for the whole picture but I was only
going to be needed for about
uh two weeks or something out of nine
months so I saw I just wrote some agent
and I was like right I'm I'm gonna ask
them to do this instead instead of like
getting me well paid work I don't know I
think I would do this and so I I went
there and I was a key set PA and so
that's my I actually got my credit on
the films that's where my my favorite
credit anyway wow that's cool we were we
were filming um the scene when
Dumbledore is up the clock tower without
giving too much away it's a very
um important part of the whole story of
the of the series
and in between takes Michael was was
outside
um having a cigarette and I was just
with him looking after him as it were
make sure he didn't run up and he was he
said to me so what are you doing at the
weekend and I said well actually Oliver
and myself were reading Peter and the
Wolf with the Halle Orchestra in
Manchester
um but I've never ridden with an
orchestra before so I'm not sure how to
you know how do you speak in time with
the music and all that kind of stuff
and that that an eyelid Michael's like
oh I've I've done that before that kind
of stuff you got the script with you I
was like yes so really she sat down with
me and went through well this is where
the music is going to come in pencil
that do this so I've literally got
dumped and he's dressed as Dumbledore
telling me all this as well so he's he's
talking me through it so I've got this
absolute Legend just I need I mean he's
you'd think in is in full right to be
preparing for the scene he's about to
shoot but he was all about you know
giving me that time to do that and
um it's it's one of those where I've
never forgot that and I I always think
that there's a like I said there's a
reason why good actors work so many
times yeah and it's it's just so
you look a lot at a lot of the great
actors and there's look there's some
real out there there's some
monsters you hear some stories but for
the most part the big ones are usually
the nice ones that have been around a
while they get it they're you know uh
you know they have nothing to prove
there's this sort of like let that go
and it's like hey let's
pay it forward and uh I mean I gotta ask
about Alan Rickman because you know he
was just legendary but he seems to me
from what I've gathered and talked to
people he was a kind man on set but he
was also you know
if if anyone you would fear a little bit
or be nervous around some some of the
guys or gals would say Rickman was a
little intimidating but he wasn't a jerk
or anything what did did you just feel
that presence like hello what is it tell
me a little bit I think somebody he was
in
he a lot of time when we were in close
proximity with him obviously he was in
Snape's full full which carries its own
oh you know presence about it but no I
mean I mean I always remember he um he
came back from an awards in the Oscars
or somewhere and he got an iPod and it
was one of the first iPod Nanos or
something like that
and he was like I've got this iPod and
we're in there and making he's like how
do you how did you make this thing work
and again like he's like in full Vape
out for it we're dressed with like Fred
and George in their school outfit and
we're there we're there putting music on
the dive
um
but that was that was the type of person
he he was about today like there wasn't
a like these guys were young going to
talk to them there wasn't any of that
going on and there was other stuff which
it's not my story to tell but I've still
I've seen